what do you think about Bitcoin you
think Bitcoin could be the solution to
all this in terms of figuring out if
it's going to hold a place in an asset
allocation or in people's spending
patterns you almost need to
prognosticate whether or not they're
going to come forth the Central Bank
digital currencies which I want these
people to monitor my bank accounts more
than they already are in the event that
I fall into the into the Trap of being
considered an Enemy of the State one of
the things that cannot be conceptualized
by people is you might not be an enemy
of the state in the year 2023 but some
Viewpoint that you have in 2033 or 2043
could be considered extremely radical
and are you sure you want a cbdc so
that's the bull case
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I've got Jeff
here Jeff uh I saw one of your tweets
that I thought would be a great place
for us to start you previously were
talking about home prices and the fact
that they exploded higher and then they
would go lower and then they would
explode higher again and you were
essentially insinuating it is nearly
impossible for the average American to
plan their life when markets are going
up and down and the cost of some of
these assets are going up and down so
much what's driving so much oscillation
between the bull and the bare cycles of
various assets
oh wow we're getting right up with the
the punch in the face to start yeah look
think about
what is a how I mean a house
it's an asset that with time
with the productivity of humankind
should be depreciating in price
I mean if you think about
pulling copper out of the ground a
thousand years ago
what the labor intensity of that may
have been as opposed to today with a
massive industrial process this is why
over the course of centuries or
Millennia you should have
structural deflation
in the cost of copper mining just to
take that example the same thing should
be the situation with a home
in that
as we develop the technology we should
be able to erect these things virtually
costlessly
50 or 100 years hits I mean this is if
you you look at something like a corn
production chart from the Great
Depression till today how efficient
we've gotten in producing these types of
things and so you have this asset
that seemingly goes up every single year
home prices U.S home prices
Canadian home prices British home prices
you name it
solely because of the monetary mechanism
really because they keep printing money
and we have these boom and bust Cycles I
mean what we had in in this situation 15
years ago with home prices you never
occur that shouldn't be an asset that
does this ebb and flow how do you
engage Family Planning or retirement
planning when you have a I don't know
five hundred thousand dollar house you
don't know if next year it's going to be
worth 300 000 or 700 000. this is the
whole point of having these central
banks was
pitched to us
a hundred years ago as it was going to
smooth out these economic cycles and
it's how many booms and busts do we have
to have between the stock market the
housing market various other markets I
mean it's
we want to have stock market booms and
crashes we could just go back to 1929
the Federal Reserve was still of its
infancy at that point so it's it's kind
of silly season and this particular
housing market is um
being the best word to describe it is
dysfunctional so when you look at um
kind of this boom and bust cycle uh this
is literally a story as old as time
right and I say that and people was like
oh yeah that's our thing I've heard
before but uh one of the things that
people don't know is that time was
literally invented because of the church
and they were trying to actually use
measurement and kind of do all this
stuff at that same moment in human
history they also were debating boom and
bust cycles of economies the price of
Interest like all these different
components uh that were kind of going on
and we're still debating that stuff
today is your belief that the solution
would be just get rid of all the central
banks get better central banks like if
to understand the problem maybe
sometimes it's best to like identify
what would the solution be and kind of
what do you see as a way to actually
avoid so many boom and busts in an
economy
well and and can you just get rid of
them tomorrow after they've penetrated
every facet of the system over the
course the last hundred years it's it's
almost one of those things you can't
really rip the Band-Aid off but you need
to
um at least attempt over time to
defenestrate that might mean this is
you know you take this example in the
last what 15 months or so is the cost of
overnight money supposed to be zero or
is the cost of overnight money supposed
to be five percentage points why is this
moving by 500 basis points in the course
of 15 months one of those two numbers
was incorrect zero
or mid five I mean heckins at some point
we made by the time this year's out get
to a six handle on on fed funds
and
with each passing cycle
these central banks are becoming more
and more you're going to make sure I
don't knock this coffee off the ledge
here these central banks are becoming
more and more powerful I mean
what happens is your your brain
starts to
repaint pictures
from prior times if you look at the old
Federal Reserve from the 1970s people
didn't know who these people were if you
went back to 1980 and pulled some guy
off the street and said who's Paul
holker
that guy didn't know who Paul volcker
was
like your brother your sister they
didn't know who Paul volcker was but
that's
and
you know you think about like the 87
crash that's when Greenspan
decided with Reagan to form the plunge
Protection Team
and I remember
with my misspent youth around the turn
of the century saying you know there's
this thing it's called The Plunge
Protection Team and their point is to
come in and prevent another 87 crash
what are you even talking about what's
the Federal Reserve
you can speak to an educated person 20
or 25 years ago say Federal Reserve and
they didn't know what you were talking
about
that that what I remember that was the
situation and we thought Greenspan was
powerful
the Greenspan took rates down to one
percent that was considered outlandish
when Greenspan went to one percent to
try to save the NASDAQ at the turn of
the century that was a wild
situation in terms of Central Banking
circles and you know what
everybody who vilified him for doing
that was right that created
what it is not create pump what did not
create think about what that did you
were lining up to purchase
Condominiums sight unseen in o30405
because Greenspan went to one percent to
try to save the NASDAQ because greenspin
was allowed to create the PPT
10 15 years before that and then
be getting all the experiments with
Denver nanki you know Bernanke wanted to
study the Japanese situation and the
Great Depression so they gave even more
power to Bernanke than green Spin and
now here we're in this situation
people are frozen in their houses
mortgage rates are seven percent we now
suddenly this guy wants to be The
Reincarnation of Paul volcker and it was
like well zero percent policy the right
rate now we're in the mid fines wants to
keep going the inflation ran out of hand
it's just how do you structure a society
when you have the cost of money being
determined by committee like this it's
it's a mess so one of the things uh I
find fascinating is the Fed doesn't just
set the rate of money it also gives
forward guidance and it will tell you we
believe it's going to be at X
um there's two schools of thought one is
if they say it's going to be at X and
they don't put it there they lied they
knew they were going to do it right and
they lied I think that's probably a
little extreme on the other hand it is
uh they thought it was going to be at X
and they were off and so it ended up
being at y now if that is a 25 or 50
basis point difference so be it
when it's a 500 basis point difference
that seems like a pretty big Miss
and so if you worked at a company and
you were off by 500 basis points and
something so important many would
consider the single most important
metric at your job
you'll be fired
right and so like help me understand in
terms of like do you think it is
malicious do you think it's just
incompetence is it actually just maybe a
third option which is like this stuff is
hard and the economies are complex and
like humans are ill-equipped to be uh
accurate in any sort of prediction like
how do you think through this
you notice your own confidence level
um decline
as the years go on
you could say it in the comments section
on your replies in Twitter you can kind
of sometimes feel oh this this person's
20 years old this person's 25 years old
their confidence of what the future will
hold
they don't have a large experience of
being woefully incorrect on those
forecasts I do I've been wrong on stuff
I remember you know years ago oh
inflation's around the corner interest
rates are going to rise and it was the
exact opposite well we always had
inflation they manipulated the numbers
but
I would have never saw negative interest
19 trillion in negative bond yields for
example I was thinking rates were going
to rise
get out of your 20s get into your 30s
get a little bit more humble I'm only in
my 40s with each passing day I'm more
humble than the prior day because
you look at things oh man this is really
going to happen I think next year such
and such is going to happen to the
economy and the next year rolls around
and it's incorrect and so
is the word incompetence to describe
Sandra Banks more like impotence
the act of saying
four six quarters from now I expect the
economic situation to look like X is an
extremely difficult task
and we hang our hats on this I mean you
would think a laissez-faire system would
be
a better path for the cost of money I
mean what we've just spent five what
five decades doing rightly
is saying okay well wait a minute the
wage and price controls in early 1970s
um
boy that was a Fool's errand
can't have a the state determine the
price of wages better determination is
let's negotiate our wages
you and I you're my employer let's say
and I'm your employee let's negotiate
wages or the price of gasoline that was
a mess
from the first oil embargo that was a
total mess trying to put price controls
on gasoline but then we turn around
and we say no it's
let's put this committee together and
determine the cost of overnight money it
doesn't make any sense how is it in in
the bizarre thing about it is is we have
a for all intents and purposes a 100
Universal consensus that gasoline price
controls of the early 1970s
is Funk economic quackery 99 out of 100
economists
but don't dare say that the committee
at the Federal Reserve
of appointed economists When anybody
with some humility says this stuff is
really difficult they yeah
maybe we shouldn't have give them so
much power I mean it's it's really it's
really
bizarre to me
um the existence of this situation and
now we've got
messes all over and what do you do with
with the situation where you're in the
stock markets it's something like 19
times forward earnings and now suddenly
the old Tina concept right there is no
alternative
this was the rationale behind buying
let's say the s p in 2021
was there is no alternative what am I
going to do I'm going to take all this
nay I'm going to take negative yielding
German Boons ah give me the s p
something like that well now there is an
alternative you can just go into Cash
and so now do you create this situation
because of all of these
the Ridiculousness of it keeping policy
at zero percent rates when home prices
were zooming like that when we had a
Raging Bull Market that commenced in the
first quarter of 09
I mean you were 11 12 years deep into a
bull market and you were still keeping
money at zero percent
and now
there is this alternative
and now you have a society where you're
entering 2024
and at the margin
somebody who's in the interest in the
business of deploying Capital may say
I do not see as much appeal to pulling
Capital into the equity into the into
the common Equity of corporate America
as to as opposed to just parking it over
here in that money market fund
that's problematic
that's problematic and and there needs
to be a happy medium and I that that
would be the concern that would be the
concern like you know give me five five
and a quarter five fifty on a two-year
Treasury and I just wake me up in a
couple years from now so it's we'll see
how it ends up playing out so one group
that did that is the banks and uh what
is interesting is that these Banks
mistimed their purchases they
essentially were buying you know 15
basis points to 50 basis point type debt
uh and they were buying it on Mid to
long duration uh uh kind of treasuries
or Assets Now as we've seen when
depositors showed up and said giving
back my money they were underwater on
that and so I think that there's a
strong argument that there was Risk
mismanagement by the executive teams of
those Banks but can we also point to the
central bank and say that maybe the
Central Bank whether through
incompetence malice or just the
complexity of doing their job
actually put the banks in the position
to buy the debt which then led to the
banks imploding
it's the basic business model
uh uh of the bank right is and you you
essentially have no choice but to
purchase these long-dated Securities and
remember the action in 2022
in terms of the you know like an
aggregate Bond index or the long end of
the yield curve was some of the most
brutal
um fixed income
returns that they had since 1994 and so
you know you essentially
mess things up I mean what is it 600
billion dollars in Market losses that
that need to be uh accounted for in the
banking system I mean it the issue at
hand is and we'll see how this plays out
I have been more concerned
at the end of the third well third
quarter the third month around March
you know with this concept that I've
been calling the bank walk and pomp I
don't know if you've heard me
say this the you know the bank walk
some people say you know the the risk is
that it becomes the bank Trot I mean for
example explain that
yeah okay
um
well I have a lot of fears on the
Bangkok and this is the this is the
issue where it's it kind of feeds upon
itself and the other the other thing in
the background of course is that what we
had here was a mismatch
of of
short and long duration Securities the
question is does it end up
deteriorating into a situation where
it's at your your credit book
goes complete in in 2024 but
you know I've given this some some good
thought this is the way I kind of lay
those out is that we are numerical
beings I mean
round numbers matter to people you have
your 50th wedding anniversary it's more
important than your 49th wedding
anniversary in your 51st but is it only
because we just think in tens
and
your stock hits a hundred dollars and
that's
a one percent move from 99 to 100 you
kind of notice it more
and
treasury three percent and I say broke
through four percent today what was the
difference between yesterday when it
went from 380 to 390. it goes from 390
to four it's more important to us
the psychology of it
and I think what happened or is
happening we'll we'll have to see with
the banks I think this is critical to
note is
you have your number
in anything and that number is is what
prompts you to act
and when your bank account is paying you
0.01 percent
and a lot of them are
and well okay here's Jay Powell at zero
percent so you just what am I going to
do I'm at 0.01
and then the Fed
takes money market rates up to one you
know it's one percent of it but you
don't really notice and one of the
reasons I say this because maybe you
notice and I notice
but to the rest of the people in society
that aren't living this every day do
they notice they don't they get their
own jobs they're doing their own thing
they're an optometrist they're in lawn
care whatever they do for a living
they're not living
money market rates like me
and so at one percent money market rates
all right you just keep it over here at
uh Bank of America earnings 0.01 or at
your Regional Bank
and then next thing you know it's two
percent like oh there's 199 basis points
gap between the 0.01 that they're paying
me and the two percent I could get if I
actually bothered to click the button
now over here off screen this is my
screen with my to-do list sometimes
I got like 90 things on this to-do list
what are we gonna do oh I gotta go get
the oil changed at some point that's on
the to-do list uh you know the kid
kicked the soccer ball in the house
broke the window I gotta get a window
guy in here
call the window guy next week I don't
have time to call this window guy
I don't have time
to move this checking account into a
money market fund because I've had this
banking relationship for 10 or 20 years
I'll do it next week
next week comes around and that
optometrist does not move that money or
that small business owner or that CFO
of the mid-sized business
at three percent the money's still not
moving at some number some
psychologically critical number
between the 0.01 percent there becomes a
spread that act that moves that thing
from number 77 on the to-do list to
number one where you say whatever it is
you got in there ten thousand dollars
ten million dollars
all right money market rates are now for
I need to get it out of First National
Bank of my local city
and that money moves that's the bank
walk and the reason it's the walk and
not the run is because when svb and
signature were going under that's the
run this money needs to move now I don't
have time to eat this sandwich the money
needs to move now
the bank walk is what am I doing here
I've got this checking account they're
paying me you know
screw that
I'm moving the money that's the bank
walk and then at five percent
the bank walk really accelerated
and the next thing you know they're good
we'll see I mean j-powell might want to
go to six percent there's a lot of these
Banks I think the national average
savings account rate is it it's 0.5
something it's it goes up like a basis
point a month it's like 53.54 basis
points at this point
you could drive a truck through that Gap
so we're gonna have an issue here where
a lot of this money is going to shift in
the money market funds that is a well
because there's going to be a lot of
debt if you buy the federal government
so that's people buying the treasuries
but
at the margin does that
local bank or that mid-sized Bank have
the capital to give you the marginal
loan on
your restaurant Venture that you want to
engage in or big question mark
your office building that's its own
issue right I just don't have the
deposit base maybe my marginal
propensity to lend you
um on your small building or your house
or your personal loan that stuff starts
to get cramped and we're going to see
that we're going to see if the if the
bank walk ends up
perpetuating itself I mean it's kind of
even out truth be told in the last month
or two but that's one of the issues and
that's
one of those I think unintended
consequences when you ratchet up rates
by 500 basis points in 15 months
what's fascinating to me about this is
um
as the rates went up people got frozen
their businesses got frozen they got
frozen geographically like the rate
definitely created friction in an
economy so if you think low rates tons
of liquidity lots of greasing of
transactions people are doing all kinds
of crazy stuff the opposite is now true
talk about this freezing of people in
their homes where they can't sell their
homes they can't buy new homes they
can't move it just feels like across the
United States there's this great freeze
that has occurred what's driving
there's I mean and and the word freeze
applies to that and also applies to your
willingness to spend on discretionary
items in 2024 partly because a lot of
that money was I was doing a a tweet
storm on this earlier words
a lot of the money has been spent from
the covet money
and so it's not only a freezing in place
on the housing which is one of my
favorite issues but it freezing place on
whether or not you're going to buy a
washing machine
in 2024 because you bought it
remember pop they were giving out
there's so many stimulus programs you
forget this stuff
there was a one point
it was something like let's say you were
uh husband and wife and and two kids
and it was twelve hundred dollars for
the husband twelve hundred for the wife
500 for the kid the kids in diapers and
500 for the other kid
and
you know you talk about freezing
well if that couple had like a
seven-year-old functioning dishwasher
during covet like oh you know this thing
doesn't clean these dishes there's spots
on these dishes I hate this thing in a
normal world
you hate the dishwasher but your middle
class you ride that dishwasher out until
the thing conks out on you then when you
wake him hey why is this button dead on
me or it's leaking onto my flooring all
right fine I'll buy another dishwasher
that's the way that's the middle class
mindset
heck
that's the upper class mindset too I
mean you don't replace something that's
generally functioning and but if you
suddenly had three grand coming in or
whatever the number is
in the middle of covet and you knew that
dishwasher was the bane of your
existence then you were scrapping a
functioning dishwasher and purchasing a
new one in 2020 or 2021. and so the
freeze on that side is
well now you've got a two-year-old
dishwasher and so does an inordinate
mass of society
and that group of people are not in the
market naturally for a 2024 dishwasher
and that applies down the list
you know the the vacation you always
wanted to take to some location that
tickles your fancy you took that
vacation
the um
you know like my wife my weakness might
say you have really want a nice watch
yeah well maybe that watch was purchased
and so you wonder about discretionary
spending now
that's one kind of the freeze now I
think what you were referring to was the
the golden handcuffs
on housing and this is one of those oh
this is such an interesting topic and
and
it parlays into so many other topics uh
you know in a situation where labor
Mobility is is rigid on account of
people stuck in their homes
is that the type of world where you want
to buy 40 and 50 times uh multiples on
stocks
um in a in a grinding and put a stick in
the gears type of maybe it's not a
depression maybe it's not even a deep
recession just
just a muddling through and it could be
a multi-year modeling and what I don't
think people fully realize because
they're not in it yet
is that more and more people will
realize it and what is it is that
mortgage rates
got up into the into the unknown Zone
here where it's a rate of change
situation it's not the mortgage rates
got to five got to six got to seven and
that we compare that to historical
mortgage rates what's important is that
we compare it to to where they were at
the trough sub three percent on the
conforming Mortgage in this country
and
I think people are passively aware but
if they're not in the market to be
moving
or shifting their life circumstances
they only know what they're hearing
second hand on this and
with each passing day
somebody else gets divorced
somebody else has a baby
somebody else dies and these are
catalysts among many to move homes if
you leave
you're in New York and there's a job
offer next door in Pennsylvania
how are you going to do that you gotta
you're locked in at two and seven
eighths
you're locked into two and seven eighths
if you wouldn't move from New York to
Philly here's your seven percent
mortgage how are you going to do that so
there's a labor Mobility
um issue and it goes much deeper than
that but um
uh
it doesn't end tomorrow
how does it end
well you wonder if at something like a
thought well who knows what the number
is but it's some lower rate do these
stuck sellers finally get to the point
where they can liquidate and this is you
know I mean if they keep short money
anywhere up here in the fives
all right so you're looking at what's
where are we on a 10-year T note 380
390.
um normally
the mortgage should be like
150 ish over a 10-year Treasury
so let's say it's 390 I got it I gotta
look at the cloaking I don't know 390
plus 150 so it should be about 540 in a
normal Market
but we've got a skittish market and we
know that money is tightening
um
and we'll see if it tightens further and
so you know the mortgage News Daily is
like 708 on it on a mortgage so you're
several hundred basis points higher in
fact the level the level of spread from
a 30-year mortgage to a 10-year t-node
and that is the comp because 30-year
mortgages don't last 30 years people
move people pay them off
so the comp is a 10-year Keynote
um
that spread is as wide as it was during
the global financial crisis
and the issue that I think are going to
increasingly see is you're going to see
old people
retirees in five bedroom houses they
prefer to be in a two-bedroom apartment
in Fort Lauderdale but they're stuck in
a five bedroom place in Minneapolis
and young people
with kids
that in a normal world may have the
means to be purchasing a three or four
bedroom single-family home stuck in a
one or two bedroom apartment
because either they have the two and two
and three quarters two and seven eighths
mortgage
um
uh or they're renting now
there is some trigger number where the
math starts to work better for you to
list the house and then you get that
increase in labor Mobility but I just
don't know that it's fully appreciated
and I I worry that the societal
dissatisfaction I mean we all see these
statistics X percent of Americans think
the country's going the wrong direction
that will rise with each passing day
and and kind of the theory I've said to
this is like okay
let's say it was 2022 and and the thing
happened that thing is a baby got born
or you've reached retirement the thing
that catalyzes the move
he said well I can't do it we gotta wait
around where we can't even list this
house we can't buy another house and
that affects this percentage of the
public
be ready to move in 2022 but can't do it
cohort
as the days go on somebody else is
having a baby somebody else is dying now
you have the 2022 cohort they're angry
and then also and then it's 2023 they're
still in that cohort they can't do it
now either and now these new people are
arising are rising to the occasion of
can't move totally stuck
and
I don't like a six percent mortgage gets
it done I mean it's literally it's
literally if you just go to a mortgage
calculator
if you're in something like a typical
three let's say you're in a three
bedroom home
and you want to move to a four bedroom
home and leave the old mortgage and go
to a new one you're looking at trampling
your payments
traveling because everybody refly during
covet and so
you think about like these issues where
oh you know a company wants to move its
headquarters
to another state
well I'm I'm in Chicago I know that
story well
everybody's been taking the stuff out of
the loop and moving it moving into
another state
well you're gonna have to pick up new
staff once you're in that other state
once you're in Florida wherever it may
be because you
my case these Illinois people they can't
pick up and leave they're locked in at
three percent so it's it's it's it's
weird and it's wacky and it's it's a
problem for hiring
in that if we still have a demand for
workers and you really have the ideal
candidate they need to be 100 virtual
worker because you're not going to be
able to get them to move
a large distance unless you pay them so
handsomely so as to justify the job
transfer and I'm not sure that that
concept
is fully appreciated
when you see the FED sitting on the
sidelines watching all this happen do
they care do they care if asset prices
are crashing do they care that people
are frozen in their homes do they care
that they've essentially created this
destruction or are they just looking at
a tight labor market and an inflation
number that seems to be coming down on
the headline you know trailing 12 months
and they're saying
we should we deserve a trophy get get
out a birthday cake for us because we're
doing a great job
well one of the weird things is that
this this they want to create
unemployment
that is a major communication disconnect
um
one's like well
I you know I can't get in the minds of
Jay Powell and what whether or not he
cares or I mean I guys probably a decent
guy who knows but it's
I I just don't understand what was it
that you were witnessing that would have
kept you in quantitative quantitative
easing for so long we were at full
employment
um
you know we've been
oh there's some four percent
unemployment for quarters and quarters
and quarters at this point and the
inflation was readily apparent I don't
know whether or not it's just
living in this Silo where you don't like
maybe
maybe Jay Powell just doesn't go to this
guy probably doesn't go to the
supermarket on his own do you remember
when he said uh somebody asked him at a
uh press conference about income
inequality
and the only reason I remember him
saying this is because we had a field
day with it on the internet he said no
one has come into my office and told me
that they're falling behind because of
our policies like I'm paraphrasing like
something like that and so of course
it's like hey man
I'm like a educated person who knows
what the Federal Reserve is and I know
the power that you have both to create
and Destroy wealth I don't know where
your office is if I wanted to come tell
you that I I don't think they'd let me
in the building
like like what do you mean that you're
not creating incoming quality just
because no one told you it like the
people who are suffering at the you know
kind of the feet of your policies they
don't even know who you are
all they say is the grocery store prices
are going up right
you know if you put your stuff in the
shoes of like a 2021 situation
where
I mean it's not even like you know
before.com
in terms of speculative excesses
you really got to go back to 1929. and
so
you know imagine if if we're living in a
parallel universe where it's
30 40 50 years after 1929.
you can forgive well maybe you can
forgive because they've forgotten about
a Mania that occurred within the span of
their own adult lifetimes now I've told
you I'm not very old
but I was paying attention and I was
on top of the.com bubble that happened
when I was a teenager and so I've had a
spidey sense for bubbles and speculative
excesses ever since then that I would
hypothesize a central bank Governor
would too
I mean
for crying out loud for crying out loud
what
is someone
whose job is to manipulate the monetary
mechanism
what is someone doing as a this person
whoever this person may be uh
a central bank a governor of one of the
12 Regional Banks or something what are
they doing
on a daily basis as a matter of their
Hobby
in 1996 1997 1998 before they reached
this current state of their career where
they are at the Pinnacle of their career
my death
they were watching CNBC
like I was
and watching eBay rip and watching Yahoo
rip and watching pets.com and and truly
told back then watching Coca-Cola and
Pfizer and General Electric and all
these other ones that were just
absolutely zooming on previous Pie in
the Sky type concepts of the ERA this is
when I was a teenager because I'm like
because I'm a geeky guy that's
interested in the stock market
and that's what I did
and that's what you do if you have
aspirations of being a extremely
high-ranking person in a central bank by
the time you're 40 or 50 or 60 years old
like these people okay so now that's why
you spent your late 1990s
all right and then
Turn Around from the from the NASDAQ
high in March of 2000 and it's only five
years later you see the most legendary
housing level so now you've got two
under your belt
that you would think would be gut
punching
because you really kind of have to think
about like these things just you know
booms and busts and maybe if you're of
the older variety you know you know
Japan in 89.90 maybe you've got 300 your
belt who knows
and I'll give a little hat tip to the 87
crash too maybe that was something that
would be forming in someone's psyche and
then now here 2021 rolls around
as like
mean stocks
and
these you sold this stuff on Twitter
with these with these these Knuckleheads
you know purchasing 50 properties and
they're out there by the pool with
champagne and and all this stuff and
they don't they don't have they don't
have two nuggets of wisdom in their head
they're making their money solely
because of a low cost of of debt on a
levered asset
and on and on it goes I mean what was
the rivian IPO
100 billion
and so you're sitting there
ostensibly having watched a.com on CNBC
in your afternoons from your dorm room
or from the comfort of of your you know
your office where you're working in
Money Management in the 1990s and then
you watch the housing bubble of which it
may have affected your own personal
properties because you're an established
player in global finance and maybe you
own properties in Southern Cal or South
Florida where that was the Pinnacle of
the housing bubble
it was like what's going on here we how
many specs needed to Launch
in 2020 and 2021 for you to take money
off of zero percent
my favorite part of this whole situation
was that the stock market was ripping
inflation was at seven percent they were
still suppressing interest rates at zero
and they were buying Assets in the
market and they were surprised when it
went to nine because I believe at the
end of 2021 they were still saying uh
they thought that it was going to be
transitory it was like only right at the
very end they start to give up on the
transitory stuff
and so in some way seven percent
inflation still did not convince them
that maybe let's take the foot off the
gas
well and then there's a hole and this is
here's the problem
with this is that
um and I've said this in the past I mean
I went off to school
to study things like interest rates and
stock market valuations and as the years
went on and this has always been the
case with you know macro type things at
one point I had to be become an amateur
expert in Greek politics
right during that during that Saga with
Greg's it's and then you have to become
a an amateur expert in British politics
for brexit and then you have to become
an amateur epidemiologist
and so on
and the truth of the matter is is that
because of the existence of these
committees that determine the cost of
money we have to be
psychologists
in that can you imagine
I mean you don't know me
but imagine if your job was for you to
assess
the fears and aspirations of Jeff
lenager
and how that may affect what Jeff
winegar is going to do to interest rates
in six weeks
or what tie color you wear or how long
you talk or whatever other nonsense
thing that people have invented to try
to identify if he's giving signals to
the market
well and then here's so here's my theory
I mean it's like
what this could be so wrong in fact it's
the odds are that this theory is wrong
but here's the theory
you're J Pavel the SPAC Boom the rivian
IPO
the speculative excesses
GameStop
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable that
they were engaging not only not QT but
active QE during all this
and now there's egg on their face I I
can't believe I did this in retrospect
you know specs and all this
now I don't want to go down in history
as the person
that led inflation rip now I need to
go the complete opposite extreme
to redeem myself Jay Powell
as the new coming of Paul volcker and
you know it's it's kind of like um
I think it's kind of like the way you
say oh
oh you know my my father never spent any
time with us as kids therefore I'm going
to spend so much time with the kids you
you know or
like these 180 degree things like this
this this occurred to me and so now I'm
going to make sure that I do the exact
opposite or or the other one is you do
exactly like your father did right you
it's you there's nothing in between
and I think that there's some of that
going on well I messed up on the
inflation thing now I'm going to take it
to the other extreme and crush this
even though the disinflationary portents
are already in the system their Myriad
um
you know people often say well you know
what do you like uh you're a shill
for a deflation thesis or a disinflation
thesis like well they're actually quite
the opposite I'm just at this stage in
the economic cycle the liquidation of
the cycle
um
I mean I the logic of Medicare and
Social Security situation is that it
will inflate out it but that's one of
the disconnects when you're tweeting
stuff like hey I'm tweeting a 12-month
thesis here it's clear in the Tweet you
said 2024 that type of thing
hey you know 2030 2040 I mean yeah
they're gonna have to inflate themselves
out of this stuff but in the Here and
Now
they've already crashed inflation
this and here's one of the things that's
tough
tough to communicate in 280 characters
that's for sure
when I say Crush inflation I mean
keeping ridiculously high prices
on even Keel or no longer rising at a
rate of change
right so
you still go to the supermarket and it's
still like what I mean I got a pastrami
Sam I walked down the street here I got
up pastramis what did I get a pastrami
sandwich chips and a drink and it was 22
bucks
from the from the deli what
but it's
that it stays at 22 bucks so when a rate
of change basis I think that near term
they do end up hitting the Target
because you have the you know the global
supply chain pressure indexes come off
the boil
you know you're seeing in things like
like the empire state survey you know
prices paid uh Texas manufacturers from
the Dallas fed that's
they're basically saying um deflation
over there
there's many of these portions and and
truth be told the other thing that well
this goes back to the the CPI
calculations
CPI
it's so important for people to
understand the lagged effects of the of
the CPI situation where CPI no doubt
about it when we got to nine on CPI the
real number was higher than that
and the difference is is
the dentist and the plumber
and what was the example we were using
earlier the optometrist they all know
that it's the economist that doesn't
know that do they not know it or did
they know it and they were lying because
I find it so hard to believe that an
intelligent Economist can look at the
CPI metric and all of the coverage
that's out there
critiquing it and said nope I think the
CPI is correct
I think that I think that this
that the street knows the CPI is
incorrect but what happens is is I mean
think about what I do for a living
I open up my charts I'm looking at my
charts writing research for wisdom trade
you just look at it so often you're so
used to saying the CPI is this and if
everyone else is looking at it then you
kind of have to use it because it's the
metric that everyone uses
right it's a data feed it's a it's
literally a Time series and you're
looking at it and CPI is four percent
right now and that's the number well
that number doesn't really reflect
reflect reality sometimes it's too wise
and that's too low most of the time it's
underestimating inflation
or the overall majority of the time it's
underestimating inflation because of the
the so-called hedonic adjustments and
I've picked on these hedonic adjustments
on the automobile side at Great length
and I say here's my deal I mean you got
to kind of know me a little bit but
here's my deal on autos
here's what I want you to sell me
the safest car that you can manufacture
that's going to get me from point A to
point B
with the highest probability that we
will survive a car crash
and give me SiriusXM Radio
and give me Heating and Cooling
sell me that car
you can't sell me that car because now
the darn thing comes with some video
screen for the kids to watch movies in
the back seat which I don't want in fact
that's the antithesis of what I want
it comes with heated seats that's going
to really help you in Phoenix
it comes with well I could deal with
those these automatic windows are pretty
nice it's got 37 000 buttons in the
center console that I don't want to push
and not only that but those buttons are
flat screen stuff so I have to convert
my eyes from the road which is not what
I want to do because I what I want from
this discretionary purchase is again the
safest thing that will get me from point
A to point B I don't need to impress
people with my vehicle
I got kids back there
but you must purchase all of these
things that come with the vehicle
and you must pay for it and in so doing
they say well when you look at a 2023
model of a vehicle and compare that to
Something in 1993 look at how much
better all these things are and I'm okay
with the hedonic adjustments
for the sake to eat the onset of the
anti-lock brake the onset of the airbag
the better seat belts the crash tests
all that stuff
but you're paying for all these things
that you don't really want and then what
you do is when you run a Time series
on what's actually happened with cars
we're like forty eight thousand dollars
on the average new car in this country
um you run a Time series on it the price
of the new cars goes like this
and the price of the CPI goes like this
I'm looking at my screen so I can see
myself like this
and we say oh Auto inflation is X
percent every year
no it's not like that at all and you
know they they messed up
I mean the BLS
that the housing
calculations in there are just so weird
um you know how they do
the the the cost of ownership with the
owner's equivalent rent
my mind my favorite
um
is that they still send people
physically into the store to find the
thing on the shelf and write down the
number
like no you can't you ask any man or
woman in America if they can send their
significant other to go to the [__]
grocery store and get exactly what they
told them to get
it's impossible
and then do it with a whole list of
things and expect it to have 100
accuracy there's no way
yeah wow and then I mean it's things
have changed through the years I mean uh
correct me if I'm wrong but and maybe
this is where the hedonic adjustments
come in but when I was a kid
I could be so wrong with this but when I
was a kid I feel like ground beef was
ground beef here's the ground beef
take it and now it's like well there's
grass-fed ground beef and there's 95
lean and all this and then they've got
that like impossible Burger stuff I
don't know if that's oh that's a
nightmare
nobody wanted to eat that
um
not me I don't want to eat that um what
do you think about Bitcoin you think
Bitcoin could be the solution to all
this in terms of a programmatic monetary
policy without a central bank driven by
humans all trying to guesstimate what's
going on and just say screw or not going
to respond to the rest of the world
we're just gonna do our thing or do you
think that's a nightmare as well
you know here's my problem and I here's
here's the thing I keep coming back to
with with Bitcoin and this you know I
feel like I need to to give a uh a
background here I
was
when I was getting really into this
stuff as a teenager I mean the early
books that I was reading
uh were like silver and gold bug books
yep in the 90s and I you know
is the inflation in the 1970s Gonna Come
Back
deficit spending perpetually entitlement
programs and these types of things
but I worry about Bitcoin is I mean it
does have this limitation as to how many
can be created
but if the issue is with Fiat currencies
that the dollar is backed by nothing
Bitcoin is also backed by nothing
so that's going to be you know it's so
let me let me throw a
um an idea because I think that this is
uh this is my response and I think
people in the Bitcoin Community but it
is a theory just like anything else
because to your point gold is something
that is physical you can pull it out of
the ground you can touch it you know all
the benefits of of gold Etc
if you think about the world that we're
heading into and I was to ask you what
is the most valuable commodity in the
world some people would argue oil or
wheat or you know whatever I would argue
computing power is the most valuable
commodity now
there's a lot of intricacies and nuances
what what it how do you measure it
what's the cost who's the supplier all
that stuff but just if you hold constant
say Okay computing power is at least
going to be very valuable if not the
most valuable commodity in the world
Bitcoin in some way that's what is
backing it right it's the strongest
computer network in the world now most
people think of backing and I put that
in their quotes is like um the security
of the network you can't hack it because
it's got this strong Computing Network
Etc
but I have this theory that like maybe
bitcoin's price is actually just putting
a value on what is the strongest
computer network in the world worth
right that the immutable kind of public
Legend like what is that worth what well
that's maybe that's just the market cap
of Bitcoin and right now we think it's
worth you know 500 to 600 billion
dollars it was worth more now it's worth
less and like that's the game
yeah I don't know it's it's and it's
it's such a difficult question because
it's new right I mean we've only had it
in this
cycle it's what it would you know 10 15
years older well I guess it's 10 or 15
years old at this point
um and we have
clearly it's you know I'm from the ETF
shop so we have a ton of Bitcoin
exposure in the British business the
American Business and so forth
you know
in terms of figuring out if it's going
to hold a place in an asset allocation
or in people's spending patterns you
almost need to prognosticate whether or
not they're going to come forth these
Central Bank digital currencies which
it's very diff well I have trouble
conceptualizing why some people are on
board
with a lot of
public policy initiatives that make zero
sense to me
I also struggled as to why anybody would
want a central bank digital currency so
I'm I want these people to monitor my
bank accounts more than they already are
in the event that I fall into the into
the Trap of being considered an Enemy of
the State one of the things that cannot
be
um conceptualized by people is
you might not be an enemy of the state
in the year 2023 but some Viewpoint that
you have in 2033 or 2043 could be
considered extremely radical
and are you sure you want a cbdc so
that's the bull case there are things
you cannot say today that you could
definitely say five years ago and no one
would have blinked and I think that's
kind of what you're getting at is uh
it's not because of anything that you do
or say that you intentionally are trying
to be malicious or
um uh have an alternative Viewpoint it's
that culture and Society can change and
therefore if you don't change with it
you kind of you know you were inbounds
to start and now you're out of bounds
but it's not because you ever took a
step you didn't move it's just a society
I think that's been a lot of the I think
that's been a lot of the appeal
um with crypto
uh you you know you just think
everybody's got their thing
that pushes their buttons and and the
other thing is you know it's
kind of on the tail end of of well it's
it's a lot of it's a function of when
you kind of reached adulthood when you
got into the system when when these
critical life events occurred for you
um
and I was too young to be a homeowner
during the housing crash
fortunate for me
you know because I was in my mid-20s and
what if I was five years older
and I had to climb out from underneath
that thing
um in the State of Florida in California
that you know Nevada some of the worst
hit states of the housing level what
would my perception have been
on the system
right and I mean I've you know as you
can see from my earlier comments a lot
of my perceptions were formed in the
1990s watching Alan Greenspan mess
things up
I'm just a product of when I was born
and came of age and so the the
the thing that I suspect would be
advisable
for the 20 year olds and for the 60 year
olds
Mr both investigate well why is 60 year
olds so much talking about gold why is
this person so much talking about crypto
maybe I can learn something from this
person
maybe and it's hard when you're we have
so much hubris when you're 20 years old
maybe just maybe the six-year-old has
seen a lot of things and knows something
about the world
and maybe just maybe
your 60 year old perception of this
snot-nosed kid that doesn't know any
better well maybe this kid can run
circles around you on Tech
maybe you should learn what the kid has
to say too and I think that there's a
lot of that going on we're so siled
social media you could see it in your
feeds people won't listen to anybody
they you know they like on the total
attack I think for investment success
whether it's in crypto or any one of
these Alternatives uh to the dollar this
type of concept
you got to be willing to open it up a
little bit and read different
perspectives Listen to What a lot of
different people have to say because
like I said forecasting is not easy
um
and you know we've got we've got issues
here with respect to the the dollar
long term I don't know how
we're gonna get out from underneath this
wanton spending and you know when I look
at the municipal level
I don't really know what I'm getting
I got potholes everywhere
I don't get snow plow removal
snow removal like what am I why are we
spending all this federal state and
local money
like a Nordic region and what are we
getting for it and then how do we get
out from underneath this burden I mean
here
in Chicago I mean what's the number tens
of billions of dollars on funded pension
liabilities
well
what am I getting for that is the
federal government going to bail that
out
if so it's more money
that must be mustered up I mean it's
it's
you almost have to inflate away these
fixed obligations long term so I think
that's probably one of those things
that's a little bit of a disconnect when
I'm
over here tweeting this disinflationary
2024 stuff because that's where we are
in the cycle
and some of these long-term effects and
yes
we've had inflation my whole life we
just that's the other thing
that's the other thing that's
fascinating
we all talk about let's say the 2010s
for example there was no inflation in
the 2010 well no no no no no
it was just lower than normal I assure
you your rent went up every single year
in the 2010s but we we actually this is
this is where words change Minds we have
people who believe we didn't have any
inflation take the Japanese
the Japanese have been in deflation
since 1990 no they haven't no they
haven't
they're just running one or two percent
inflation they're destroying their money
at the pace of one or two percent per
year it's just not the three or four
percent that the Americans do but man
the semantics will change your world
view you got to be careful with the
semantics
when you look out over the future my
last question is
what do you anticipate happens over the
really long term does the United States
dollar lose Global Reserve status are
Americans lives better or worse than
they are today in terms of like the
quality of life
um so just more bifurcation and like
income inequality like what are some of
the things that you feel may be most
confident over the long term without
having to put a time frame on them the
most difficult way all right look
to lose dollar Reserve status
you need to have a breakdown in your
rule of law
now I think we've we've had that
it's just what is the order of magnitude
of that breakdown and and there's
the rule of law in terms of the order of
civil society that type of law
finding criminals punishing criminals of
that type of thing
and then there's the rule of contract
law
and contract law is absolutely critical
we know we broke contract law
day after day after day during the
global financial crisis
um
the General Motors bailout for example
you know is the company insolvent or is
it not insolvent
um
but the bank bailouts the insurance
company bailouts the the homeowner
bailouts back then we had we had a we
had a societal contract you purchased
this home you pay this debt off
you speculated down in Del Rey
Lauderdale Boynton that type of thing
well you need to own that we broke
contract law
as a society back then I think that that
was a uh something that brought forth
essentially you know a lot of the the
the
disconnect between the the public and
the government back then and I don't
think that was good for the dollar long
term now
over the Long Haul
you know it's like you leave a bad
boyfriend or girlfriend but you need to
have one that's better lined up
and so what are you supposed to go oh
yeah the Euro I mean we were talking 10
years ago well even recently about the
Euro breaking up that's a risk Long Haul
so I don't think you lose your reserve
set status to the euro it wouldn't be
the yen
I mean that's an economy the Japanese
economy hasn't been able to get it
together for something like 30 years so
it wouldn't be that it wouldn't be that
you know the the Chinese it wouldn't be
or NIMBY
because well who wants to move Capital
towards China
um in terms of Havens
I think that we should be heartened long
term about the quality of life in
general throughout all of history we've
only ever seen quality of life improve
there's periods of time where it will
devolve Wars you know during Wars your
quality of life declines but it's an
inexorable Pace forward
um with time I mean you know I think I
think you ask a typical person what
might be their concerns with respect
whether or not their children will have
it better off than them I would think
that maybe their concern would be their
individual rights
um you know the growth of the
surveillance state that type of thing
but generally speaking
yeah you go back to go back to the
depression in the 1930s and you know the
guy you know FDR his whole thing was
getting a chicken in every pot
like that was a big dinner if you could
get a chicken in every pot well now it's
like my wife went to Costco a chicken
was five bucks you know there were two
three chickens five bucks
um so you could put a chicken on the
table for five bucks in this country and
that's because of technological
advancement
um
you know we've we've
for the most part made Leaps and Bounds
globally and certainly in the United
States in terms of eradicating hunger or
intense poverty
these types of issues so I I suspect on
that the future is positive but you got
to make sure
that we have so many unknown
technologies that I think could really
restrict individual freedoms
in the future and I don't know that I
fully understand those Technologies I
think one of them would be the cbdc I
don't know how anybody could be in favor
of that
um and that would be something that
would be top of my mind in terms of
risks
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or learn more about the
work you're doing at Wisdom Tree
well I'd say most of the stuff that you
would see it's a lot of I do a lot of
macro work on Twitter
the Twitter stuff is um really how we
get the message out because Wisdom Tree
is a mid-sized asset manager we
specialize in dividends
primarily but we have businesses across
asset classes
um I do some posts on LinkedIn as well
we have the wisdom tree blog I write
white papers
um and then I do you know I do pods like
this I do a lot of TV spots but I'd say
if you want to get your everyday dose of
whenever I'd say hit me up on Twitter
and if you like macro that's what you'd
find there
Jeff I've learned so much today I really
appreciate taking the time to do this we
definitely will do it again in the
future
um and I just appreciate I think kind of
uh your humor your uh understanding of
the nuances of the macro environment but
also you're willingness to uh just kind
of say it how you see it which is
increasingly rare in today's societies
so thank you so much and we'll
definitely do it again
thanks Anthony all right take it easy
man